CBS News legal analyst Ricky Kleeman is
with us and she watched the bar hearing
in its entirety yesterday and as you
heard she's got it yeah morning all
right so much to get through so let's
tick through this quickly and nobody is
better at that than you first Congress
what if they hold the Attorney General
in contempt of Congress what would that
look like well what has to happen in
order to hold anyone in contempt of
Congress is you subpoena that person
this person refuses then at that point
you have to have a vote in Congress in
order to hold them in contempt then at
that point if it is still refused how do
you enforce it so you can have a fine of
course but you would have to go to court
in order to get an order to literally
arrest someone and bring them in really
an uncharted tarring critics say that
the Attorney General the United States
looked more like the president's defense
lawyer then the Attorney General and
chief law enforcement official is he
supposed to be more independent he is
supposed to be totally independent and
impartial you have to remember that the
Department of Justice although it is
part of the executive branch it is
supposed to be the arbiter of fairness
what we heard a great deal of not only
yesterday but in his statements and
written statements before is he worked
as an apologist for the president about
the president's frustration and his
feeling about an inability to govern as
a result of being quote/unquote falsely
accused what William bar winds up saying
during the course of testimony is that
any president not just this president if
he or she believes they are being
falsely accused they have the right to
get rid of that accuser that is a very
dangerous precedent indeed did bars
testimony yesterday really make the case
more than ever that we need to hear from
Robert Muller there is no doubt that if
we didn't think we needed to hear from
Robert Muller before yesterday by the
end of yesterday we certainly know we do
and it is for good reason
William bar is abundantly clear which i
think is very disturbing that he and rod
Rosenstein came to a conclusion about
approximately 10 episodes of obstruction
of justice or potential obstruction of
justice
using a standard in a criminal case of
proof beyond
reasonable doubt he says in his
testimony that he doesn't know why
Robert Muller came to a conclusion which
I call it a conclusion of equipoise
there is a evidence about obstruction
but yet there isn't evidence about
obstruction enough to convict in a
criminal case so who has the primary
evidence Robert Muller but bar but he
left it in bars lap and so bar having
had it left in his lap made the call
well it certainly could be said that
Robert Muller intended perhaps to leave
it in Congress's lap don't you think
that Congress has the right to ask that
question well it asks it of itself it
doesn't have to ask the special counsels
handed it all off why does he have them
because we don't know and Congress
doesn't know when he looked at
approximately ten episodes with sub
episodes beneath them Don began his the
legal counsel for the president being
the most egregious that we can lay our
hands on and then find out why he came
to that content there's quickly you know
senator Klobuchar in her testimony tried
to make the case that what she learned
in law school law school was that you
look at the totality of the evidence and
a pattern here doesn't that matter what
those ten instances of potential
obstruction I thought Amy Klobuchar gets
an a-plus because she had a goal in her
questions and she got to it she talked
about lingering those pardons putting
them out there and acts of obstruction
and why doesn't the totality bring us to
a different conclusion really it's the
more we hear the more questions we have
yes we're still not getting all the
answers thank you very much Ricky
Clayman